So where are we, Dan?
Where are we heading?
North of the border.
We're on the road again.
We are going to
the Ke-new-ka Inn?
Kinneuchar Inn.
How do you say it?
People who know
and are from here.
it's pronounced Kinneuchar.
Kinneuchar.
It's an interesting place
because they use almost all
of the produce from the estate
in which the restaurant is
located.
So some of the supply line
problems won't have hit them.
That's good.
That makes sense.
It's a real farm
to fork operation.
They're aiming for
self-sufficiency,
and I don't think
they're far away from it.
TIM HAYWARD: Well, I'm
looking forward to it.
I hope the weather holds.
James, Hi.
Hi.
How are you doing.
Nice to see you.
Good to see you.
It's good to meet you.
Nice to meet you.
So what do we got here, James?
So this is Bowhouse.
We're on the Balcaskie Estate.
And then just down
the way here is
where we have all our veg
growers, Tom and Connie.
And then just literally
down the road,
we've got some Monans and
Pittenweem, which is...
That close?
That close.
Yeah.
Where we get all our
fish and shellfish.
And then in here
is the butchery.
OK.
So you'll check it out?
So I'll leave the
butchery to you guys.
Maybe I'll see you at the veg.
I'm vegetarian of course.
Wow.
This is big.
So what have we got here?
This was just a bit
of four chords meat
that I've been chopping up.
So getting some
stewing cuts out of it,
getting some little
steak cuts out of it.
So this is quite
an underused steak.
Called the petite tender.
But it's essentially sort
of second most tender
muscle next to a filet.
No one knows about it.
So it comes out right from
the middle of the shoulder.
Normally that sort of just
comes off as a big piece
and it will just get chopped
up and put in trim or whatever.
But if you just find this
little muscle and take it out.
So I'm trying to get
as many steak cuts
as I can out of each cow.
So using all these different
cuts which are traditionally
just thrown in with like
stewing or just into mince
and actually just trimming
them up to give people
more of a choice.
I don't like to
work in a kitchen
where you're just buying in
like prime cuts, you know.
And not just with cows.
Like with sheep as
well it's kind of
odd to just buy like just a
solidly rack of lamb and stuff.
It's more interesting
for me and much more
interesting for the restaurant.
And you're doing sheep
and pigs here as well?
Yep.
So sheep.
The estate have
different breeds,
which means they can actually
produce lamb all year round
because they sort of lamb
at slightly different times.
And I'm also doing quite
a lot of mutton as well.
So really getting the kind
of cull ewes that come from
the estate and-...
Tell me what a cull ewe is.
Cull ewe is just
a sheep that's not
producing any lambs anymore.
So it's done it's
kind of working life.
I think you've also got
as butcher and as a chef,
you do have a
responsibility I try
to educate people towards that.
And we should be in
cull ewe not just
because I think it's ethical,
but because it's delicious.
It's really delicious.
So here we are on the estate.
This is where you
get all the veg.
This is where we get all the
veg, which is grown by Connie.
How long have you
been here, Connie?
We've been renting land
from the estate for three,
this is our third
growing season.
It's a decent size
operation you've got.
Wouldn't you say?
It's Two acres,
three poly-tunnels.
It's a no dig system.
So you're getting 90-ish
percent of the vegetables you
use in the kitchen from here?
Yeah.
I mean we use one other
supplier which is over the way.
And all the veg
that you would say
was the blockbuster veg that
can be the star of the dish all
comes from here.
What difference does
that make when you're
getting stuff so quickly?
Sort of farm to fork.
It's more important that we can
get really high quality veg.
If we get something
that's very high quality
we don't want to mess
around with it too much.
So we won't be adding
lots of butter and puree.
We like to serve
it as it is so you
can taste how good it is and
hopefully cook it with respect.
So we're hearing a lot about
the supply chain squeeze
at the moment.
Does having access to products
like this on your doorstep
make you resilient to that?
It makes us a lot more
resilient in terms
that we don't really have to
use like large scale suppliers
or as much fruit and veg as some
places might use from Europe.
Are you one of the lucky
ones in that respect?
Not everybody has
access like this.
Yeah.
I think if you're going to have
a rural restaurant you should
be using sort of rural produce
as well that's grown out here.
Because it seems something
crazy about having
a restaurant in Fife and then
going in sort of from London
to Edinburgh via Milan
in that sense to get veg.
We work on a thing
where, like, they send me
an email on like
a Monday and then
they get the same with
Lewis who does the fish
and I know what there
is meat wise as well.
So I'll see what's in
season and then that
will govern what the menu is.
Rather than me say this
is a menu, I need this,
I'll always be like, what
do you have that's good?
Right.
Let's have that, and
then let's decide
what we're going to do with it.
And for me, that's just a more
fun, exciting way to cook.
Does that hinder your chances
of ever getting a Michelin star?
I mean...
I don't know.
Look, I imagine there's
chefs that do work like that.
A long time ago I decided
that I hadn't a big interest
in awards and stars.
What I had an
interest in was people
sitting down and enjoying food,
and that gave me pleasure.
This is all local
produce, right?
It's an amazing
selection of stuff.
Oh, that is just a beauty.
These are razor clams, right?
We call these spoose.
Spoose.
in Scotland.
Yeah.
You're a lucky man.
Yeah, I am.
Because we've got
like the veg literally
like just down the
road, and then we've
got the meat same place.
And then the fish here.
And it's that freshness
that quality that hopefully
makes its way onto the plate.
Were you involved in the
design of this place?
So there was already a couple
who were the architects.
Sort of coming on board
and doing the interiors.
And then really when
we came on board
it was sort of nine months
before the end of the project.
And so I then would
meet with the architects
because there was a sort
of whole idea of here,
but also I just needed
to come in and get
a bit more practical.
For example, the bar didn't
have that hole coming through.
I had to fight--
Good Lord.
Really?
...really hard to get
that because they said no,
it doesn't really work
with whole visual.
And I said, but this
is so necessary.
Service flow is everything.
And it's two extra members
of staff to cover the...
Yeah, so just little
things like that.
But this was really built
from the inside out.
You've ended up with an easy
utilitarianism aesthetic.
Yeah there is sort of
sparsity, but also...
Yes, austere but comfortable.
I wanted people to
feel that they're
being welcomed into our
home as it were, sort
of with the food and the
service and sort of feeling
comfortable from the
minute you arrive.
What are you doing here, James?
Yeah, sorry.
So these are the
pork pies that we've
got at the moment
in the restaurant.
So I'm just adding
the jelly, which
is traditional in a pork pie.
I can't help but notice that
you're injecting this pie.
Is that the
traditional technique?
No I used to use a jug I've
found a little bit less messy
to use the sort
of meat injector.
And also, quite
apt at the moment,
like it's getting vaccinated.
Is it going to be double jabbed?
Or triple jabbed.
It's getting like 20
times jabbed, this one.
Be completely immune from
anything by the time it's done.
Tell me about your story, James.
How long were you
working in London?
18 years working
in London kitchens?
So I grew up in a
restaurant which
was in Halifax, in Yorkshire.
And then I moved to
London and this woman
Angela Hartnett was
opening at the Connaught
and they needed
chefs to be there.
So I took the job there.
After 18 years in
London, what led you
to this corner of Scotland?
Well basically I was asked
to look at this place.
I bumped into someone
in Shoreditch.
She was looking for a
chef to take over here,
and she offered for
me to come up...
they'd pay for us to
come up and have a look.
I said yes and we came up.
Then when we saw the
produce and everything
else that was around
there, we thought, well.
Were you ever a bit concerned
it was sort of in a remote part
of the country?
Yeah!
I mean I was concerned
up to the point when...
before we opened
and when we opened.
Anyone who opens a business,
especially somewhere
they don't know.
Like an area they don't
know if they tell you
that they're not concerned, then
I think they should have been.
This place from the outside,
is it's like a corner pub
in a very, very, very small...
I suppose village
is the word for it.
Yeah.
How were you greeted
when you arrived?
What happened with the locals?
I think it was difficult,
because obviously this was
a very old, traditional pub.
Which previously everything
had been traditional fare,
as they refer to it.
So it was quite
tricky to sort of open
and people suddenly had been
coming here for 20, 30 years
to suddenly come in and just
think, what is going on here?
We opened at the end
of September 2019
and then managed
to get six months.
And we were working
incredibly hard
and we were really, really busy,
and then like everyone else
we just fell off a cliff.
We then decided to do a
sort of voluntary service
for the village.
So that we made food at cost.
I think people
really appreciated
that in the village,
and we suddenly
made quite a lot of friends.
So what happened then?
You brought some guys up from
London to work in the kitchen.
One of the guys that moved up
with his family and everything.
And then after sort of
three months of the pandemic
he decided to move back down.
And then the other
chef that was with me
that had been with
me from the start,
he didn't want to
be around anymore.
He wanted to be
down in Yorkshire
where he was originally from.
Staffing hasn't really
sorted itself out.
It's hard rurally
but I think it's
been hard in big
cities like London
as well because I think some
people have had this time off
with furlough and they've
reassessed what they
want to do with their lives.
It's been more of a
struggle to get staff.
So it's one of the legacies of
the pandemic for the restaurant
business, do you
think, going to be
that staff are going to have
to be paid a little bit more?
Well I think it's already
starting back in the day.
Like when you started off
you got paid very little
and you worked a lot of hours.
And it's like, well, you
just accepted it then.
But I think these days people
just don't want to do that.
And I can see why.
Yeah.
So you're opening up now
back up to full speed.
Yeah.
Are you finding staff?
Staffing is a problem.
You know we are
struggling to find
another chef to come on board,
particularly where we are.
Someone's got to make
sort of a life choice
to come and be here if they
want to work in a kitchen.
It does feel
positive, but I think
it's about attracting people
to come and work for us.
And therefore, we have to
manage expectations and also
look at how we run the
business and look at pricing
and all of those things.
And pricing needs
to perhaps go up
and things need to
reflect people's wages,
people's way of life.
It's trying to
find that balance.
Great food.
If you don't have
great service, it's
the two have to go hand in
hand because otherwise it
doesn't work.
Tim, when James and Alethea
came up here in 2019
after sort of 18 years
working down in London,
it was already a bit of a punt.
But then a few months later
along came Covid and completely
turn their plans upside down.
It was definitely a risk,
but strangely mitigated.
I mean they were
invited up here.
They were recruited up here
by the Anstruther family who
own the estate up here,
and there was a plan,
I think, to try and create
a little bubble of food
appreciation and foodie-ness.
It hasn't been plain
sailing, though.
Oh, God no.
They had to win
hearts and minds.
The locals didn't necessarily
take to them straight away.
Extraordinarily difficult.
But what's happened is it's
a double-edged story.
I think that they
were helped to set up.
They got started.
Covid hit.
Covid immediately hit
them very, very hard.
But also enabled them to forge
relationships with the people
around them.
Coming out of it, they've
been partially insulated
but they've also used that time
to become more flexible in what
they've thought about,
to think more creatively.
And to establish themselves.
The food we're eating
here at the moment
is the kind of stuff you'd be
expected from a place that's
been here 20 years.
It's confident.
It's well thought out, and
it mirrors the area around.
Well, speaking of, the
squid on your plate
is the same squid that we
saw freshly caught yesterday.
So they're really making the
most of this amazing produce
that's right on their doorstep.
They're protected from all these
issues around squeeze of supply
chains that we're seeing.
And they've got some
fantastic produce
which people might travel from
far and wide to come and see.
It's a fascinating
all round story.
Different from other
Covid stories we've seen,
but that's been the
most remarkable part
about going out and visiting
businesses during and after.
It's not even just
a regional thing.
It's not just that Scotland
has different Covid rules
to the UK.
It's far more than that.
It's a postcode.
Literally another village
two kilometres off
that way will have a
totally different story.
There really isn't a
difficulty getting people
to come here and eat great food.
What we're going to have
to worry about now is
are there enough people
to cook it, to serve it?
And will people pay enough
money to actually cover
the increasing costs of even
the lovely producers here.
The price of that
is going to go up.
Yes, still so much
uncertainty ahead.
But as far as I'm concerned
from where I'm sitting,
I think this is
worth every penny.
Yeah, I think you're right.